june is pride month and events are
taking place all across the valley to
celebrate inclusion and our lgbtq
community mary jane bellies joining us
live from henderson equality center with
more on some of the celebrations
underway good morning
heather and john good morning actually
we moved locations we are actually in
front of the galleria mall we're in the
parking lot where the henderson pride
fest will be taking place you can see
behind me just some of those booths and
chairs they're getting ready to set up
here we thought it'd be good to kind of
showcase what people can prepare for as
they come down here for tonight's event
and i'm joined bright and early this
morning
trevor harder you've been with us all
morning long you are the center's uh
youth program director so thank you so
much for being here and talking about
this event what can people expect
tonight so we're going to have a lot of
vendors as you can see back there we're
going to have a bunch of entertainment
fun for the whole family we have food
trucks
bouncy houses caricatures all sorts of
fun things for the whole family and you
know what's really great about this
event too is the proceeds really go back
to you guys in helping programming and
the community yeah so all of the
proceeds for the pride fest come back to
the center and they help us with all of
our programming whether that's youth
programming or our social programming
that is perfect and again tickets are
five dollars and so come out here and
really support and have fun at tonight's
event at the galleria mall tonight at 5
p.m reporting live mary jane balleza
live local now